all right so I've talked about other
actors and actresses known more for
their comedic roles about taking on a
dramatic role and they say it's not that
hard because comedy is inherently
dramatic and so I'm wondering do you
feel the same way or or was it a
challenge because Lee Israel is so
guarded was it a challenge to play it
was I mean I always think any character
is a challenge I think you try to do
them justice maybe a little more
pressure with Lee just because she was
real and there's the added thing of you
know I hope I'm doing right by her I
hope this is I hope she wouldn't hate it
which bleep probably would but she would
have liked the attention on her work but
now for me the comedy or drama de is
always secondary if I like the story and
if I like the character the approach is
the exact same and I think I've played a
lot of very challenging strong women but
they usually you know they lead they
lead outward and I thought it was really
a great challenge and also really
strangely fun to play Lee who was so
kind of everything went inert I mean her
I think unjustly she was so invisible to
so many people and I think she also used
it to her advantage
I think it's why she got away with
things because she wasn't noticed but
it's also what you know made her an
incredibly lonely person you know jack
is so in-your-face about him Lee is so
guarded and closed down do you think
they wanted to be in each other's lives
or did they need to be in each other's
lives or both I think both I don't know
if Lee would admit to either of those
things I mean Richard always says that
Jack's like the Labrador Retriever that
just keeps like no matter matter how
many times you push him away comes back
and he's just as happy every time I'm
like well I guess Lee's the armadillo
that just is completely in her own shell
but I think there's I mean it's there's
such an unlikely pair and yet they're
both so lonely and they're so isolated
in their own way and I think they
finally just met at the right time where
you know at some point you do every
human that needs someone to look at them
and actually see them see them for who
they really are and to be okay with it
to know that
surely to know jack is this grifter
who's you know probably doing every
wrong thing you can do and to be like I
know what you do I'm fine with it and
for for Jack to really see Li with for
all of her flaws and eccentricities and
to be like I'm okay with it I mean
that's that's a hard thing to do so
people that can't let people really in
these two were able to do it I think it
was kind of magic magic timing and they
didn't need it
you know jack is so kind of in-your-face
he's got this in-your-face personality
but Lee is more reserved and guarded do
you think these two people wanted to be
in each other's lives or did they need
to be in each other's lives or both no I
think they'd it's a great description of
them I think that they they have no
there was no need there was no tension
for them to be together because they're
polar opposites machiste marginally like
a porcupine jizeen and Julius bär their
Walkman headphones on she has no
interest in everybody else and he's just
you know Labrador like comes out he's
got no money what's a drink he's like
you know haven't I seen you so many
before
oh yeah you and a person from Fandango
hide you have any money can we have a
drink let's go out so he would do that
in order to sketch and grift off of
people and then it turns out that they
have I suppose loneliness in common and
a need for she he brings out something
in her that I think she hasn't really
allowed herself to to give into and he's
charming and you know chivalrous to a
degree and she kind of Falls for that
and it's completely platonic because
she's lesbian he's gay but they somehow
end up enjoying each other's company to
her surprise she says yeah this was he
said am I gonna see you again
after they met her for the first time
and she says yeah I think this was yeah
this wasn't too bad you know it's sort
of reluctantly saying yeah well maybe I
could see you again tomorrow what's
something you learned about the real
jack that best inform your performance
of him there was very little information
in Leah's rails book
x2 so eccentric writing about herself
and her great literary forgery schemes
he once she had been rumbled by the FBI
that and they were on to her that she
was the person forging these letters in
order to carry on making money she got
Jack Hawk to go and fence them in her
absence and she would somehow very often
say to him well I think you're gonna get
600 bucks so maybe 800 bucks for this
and if he'd come back with 2,000 that
was the clue for me that I thought well
this is somebody who is really good at
the subterfuge of going hi your front
fandango I've got this scheme got these
great letters and you know it's he just
manages to charm and pull the wool over
people's eyes long enough that he gets
the money out of them and I thought that
that's a talent to do that so that's as
the sliver of stuff that I went on
you